en mi amar no hay calma Después de la
tormenta el ciclón mocha azotó la parte
occidental del país dejando poco más de
una decena de heridos y cientos de casas
destruidas a pesar de los esfuerzos
gubernamentales por evacuar a los
ciudadanos antes de que mocha tocara
tierra varios perdieron la vida
cuando la tormenta se hizo más fuerte
huí de este lugar con mis hijos no
quería morir y dejar a mis hijos pero
nos hundimos en el agua y la gente tuvo
que salvarnos sacándonos del agua
el sur de bangladesh también fue una
zona afectada por las violentas lluvias
provocadas por el ciclón cientos de
miles fueron trasladados a refugios
temporales durante la tormenta y
regresaron a sus hogares para ver sus
casas destruidas las víctimas describen
su experiencia con el ciclón más fuerte
que ha azotado las costas asiáticas en
años
ayer cuando llegó la tormenta voló el
techo y las paredes de nuestra casa
entonces corrimos a refugiarnos con
nuestros hijos el viento era tan fuerte
que casi arrancaba la gente del suelo
cuando corrían muchas personas cayeron
al suelo mientras corrían en busca de
Refugio nunca habíamos visto una
tormenta semejante
los campos de refugiados rojinya minoría
étnica perseguida por la junta militar
de miamar también sufrieron daños por la
tormenta y organizaciones no
gubernamentales reportan múltiples
víctimas mortales en los campamentos el
ciclón mocha intensifica la crisis
humanitaria en la región Naciones Unidas
estima que unas 6 millones de personas
ya necesitaban ayuda humanitaria antes
de la tormenta entre ellos 1.2 millones
de desplazados por el conflicto